Blue Bloods fans were stunned earlier this
fall when the show unceremoniously killed
off one of its main characters, especially
since the actress had touted the show just
months before.
"Seven seasons later, we're as strong as we've
ever been."
As it turns out, the cast was reeling just
as much as everyone else.
The show's actors recently spoke out on the
departure of Amy Carlson, whose Linda Reagan
was revealed to be dead in the season 8 premiere,
revealing their shock and disappointment with
the character's abrupt demise.
Linda died off screen, with the show revealing
in its return that her character had been
killed in a helicopter crash months earlier.
After her exit, Carlson wrote a note of thanks
for fans who'd supported her throughout the
series.
Although she said she was grateful to the
cast and crew, Deadline reports that there
may have been some trouble behind the scenes,
with Carlson reportedly deciding it was, quote,
"time to move on" after fulfilling her contract.
While Linda's death was hard on fans, it was
also especially hard on the character's husband,
Danny, played by Donnie Wahlberg.
Wahlberg said he didn't have to stray far
from the truth to play the grieving widower.
He told the crowd at Paleyfest in New York,
"Rather than try to act or find something
to do, I just thought about my friend Amy
Carlson.
I thought about all the years together and
all the highs and lows and the ups and downs
and the journey.
Any tears I shed in that scene was really
Donnie shedding them for Amy…
Hopefully this family of our cast, the show,
and the viewers will all mourn the loss together
and move forward after this season."
Some of Wahlberg's other co-stars also expressed
their sadness at Carlson's decision to leave
the show.
Sami Gayle told TVLine, "Amy made the decision
to leave, but we adore her....
We're very sad she left."
Marisa Ramirez, who plays Danny's partner
Detective Maria Baez, thinks the departure
will prove interesting for the show because
Danny will now need to turn to her support,
adding, "...we'll see if he takes it, because
he's very, very stubborn."
Meanwhile, her co-star Bridget Moynahan added
that she was "disappointed" to learn that
the actress was departing, saying, "It was
unfortunate that she made that decision at
the end of Season 7, so we were stuck with
the storyline as we could get it.
But I'm really thrilled for her to go off
and pursue other things and follow what she
felt was best for her."
Carlson, for her part, wrote on Twitter that
she was "appalled and sad" about the comments
made at PaleyFest, saying, "I [love] the show,
cast and playing her."
"Why are ya'll looking at me?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!